na largada estamos a voltar da doença
foto web não de ir que não é k há a
suspensão pessoas de rita mas o angolano
ano ensina a ilha é ainda uma introdução
eu tenho a opinião de que as pessoas vão
pensar talvez que eu sou cantor do
kuduro ou então o o músico mas o artista
plástica clássico pronto agora as coisas
estão muito está andando muito rápido
januário mas na minha gestão mas gastar
então a mostrar um vídeo como começou
essas idéias como é que eu fui para a
telona com uma suspensão que talvez uns
paixão muita massa da vp que mônaco nem
todas são joão também mas vou explicar
como é que vem isso tudo só as fotos é
élton está em né tabela e tal mas
promete mais do mesmo já que ele já
tinha umas idéias assim hidráulicas
eólicas campeão todo lado
lá esse é o meu pai que o vende a
agricultora e por isso que eu trabalho
com as galinhas também porque em casa
temos várias linhas que fazer com as
galinhas ou fazemos para quedas e
lançavam do segundo andar
pronto lá a atropela vai matar né
desculpa aí vamos ter a sua dimensão e
da galinha vocês perceberem mais ou
menos aqui também
deixa ele passar
exato
o helicóptero um helicóptero antes da
então as galinhas caíram mas talvez essa
imagem porque buscam algum problema em
92 tap ea aac ia fazer uma uma surpresa
uma menina que gostava muito
então eu disse que ia fazer uma daquelas
declaração de amor
eu como tenho um vizinho
os pais tinham um é muito foguetes em
casa mas já que os foguetes que o natal
o ano novo eo por um foguete e fui à
casa da menina às 18 horas lance o
foguete só que o que aconteceu deixou
passar
estava apaixonado que fazer um jogo
difícil eu pensar que era isso mas não
deu nada disso acho que será assim mas
maior cv
então ela sempre a casa da menina só que
o teto da casa da menina pegou fogo ea e
até hoje ele não quer falar comigo então
depois disso uma página dela no mónaco
mas depois de um concurso que eu estive
lá prontos para seu concurso foi aceito
na escola de belas artes em um carro e
quando eu cheguei lá no japão é a via
que o pessoal superar e leva conheciam
tudo imagem simples e trabalhavam com
maya 3d studio max monday 5 de leve sim
então como é que eu vou fazer essa cena
saiu da ilha só estilo anda nunca bacon
macaca não tenha um computador lá na
ilha pronto essa opção era pescador o
meu pai vinha legumes que queria fazer
criar algo artesanal animação artesanal
fazia por exemplo vídeos
vocês vão ver uma exposição do vídeo que
eu fiz só pra entrar no movimento ter
uma uma ideia base é apenas a ovelha
à época o atleta não tem muito tempo eu
cortava o anúncio de 15 minutos e tal
vocês já perceberam é a teoria do caos o
caos deu nisso
cheguei lá e comecei a trabalhar com os
nacionais coisas simples desenho
alguns já fiz vídeos com um farinha de
trigo e pet shop em 7 e são essas coisas
simples que eu aprendi então não importa
nos vemos anos para fazer coisas
incríveis com coisas simples e básicas
né
o pack cantor viveu na ilha e que há
aqui um amigo que trabalhava com um com
madeira e fazia pensadores não tem nada
a ver não tenho nada contra o pensador
sou disse que o pensador tem que
levantar espreguiçar-se e exatamente
pronto então am
meu pai é artista de subir é paulo
sérgio reconhece que houve um problema
não tem muitas condições também de samba
vou tentar fazer isso disse tudo pode
ser que vocês têm um bom artista
trabalha com madeira tem também a
bandeira porque visto um amigo augusto
não vive bem tô mal então vou pra frança
e uns tudo aquilo que eu vivi
segundo o outro vídeo que vai vai
retratar um pouquinho que eu estou a
falar
louis
o jogo
foi comigo lá em paris e coloque uma
exposição sobre jacques tati serão se eu
queria estar nessa posição eu queria
mentir chegar lá e dizer olha não sei
muito bem porque é muito bem design não
há problema cheguei disse é verdade
porque para nós do não sair de uma
escola assim com muita força que não
tinha ficado em angola não tiver não
conhecia mitologia grega por exemplo
aprendi lá e decide fazer esse trabalho
e esse trabalho já é mostrado em várias
galerias e eu fiz com aquilo que nós
temos também que não conseguimos nesse
claro que o teclado tem um trabalho
quase lógico que eu faço com o domingo
apenas vou passar o outro vídeo explicar
a alta pronto
esse é o vídeo eu falei que eu fiz um
vídeo com farinha de trigo que shopping
sexos açúcar aquilo foi chamar o seja
artistas fazer um vídeo e na sala de
espera ou tenta inventar queria chegar
lá e dizer eu tenho uma produtora em
paris mas ele estudantes têm uma
produtora trabalho com 15 pessoas têm
todas as condições todas as câmeras
possíveis mas não cheguei dentro viu o
cantor diz olha vou dizer a verdade eu
vou fazer um vídeo de 15 euros o que
fazer com que o açúcar farinha de trigo
e vou ver e eu cantar as músicas da
vanessa trad então estava vanessa
paradis e todo aquele pessoal lá de
paris que fizeram a gente desse cantor
tiramos a lição ao jovem favor e assai
não não aceitaram se o cantor foi pra
casa começou a pensar em cliques cá
cheguei aqui com supermando no pescoço
açúcar
a farinha de trigo cuscuz o pai eu fiz
um vídeo e tive dois prêmios e esse
filho foi o vender os direitos do
colplay só vocês verem esse acordo jogou
se chegar à marriott num jogo disse o
capitão é só aquelas são só colegas dos
angolanos tirou a zona dos sonhos
eróticos pente de havana mas ficou fora
botou séria da morte se dão azo de ver
com um e legal kasting de coco natural
aberto
faltariam no rio
o sonho continua ao som
dois anos depois perde um estilo muito
longe london cicinho disse
citou pio x ou y
tira nossa pessoa perder a copa um
conjunto cada um dos oito lotes
leiloados um tucson matou doni capitão
sai do chão
giroto monte não também é difícil
a justiça
dizia
silon quilombo
então vamos voltar no tempo que já deu
uma chance então eu os vi eram
exclusivos no vídeo é porque já
trabalhei com exclusivo para fazer
aquela designação do amor na minha na
mina
a farinha de trigo com o zé povinho a
minha mãe sempre a fazer pastéis
nós chamamos de bebés então o açúcar
eu conheço o açúcar eo microfone eu só
peguei um pai do foi pra te porque o
microfone não podemos inventar uma
história temos que fazer algo assim tão
forte e tal
então essa veia que eu tô desenvolver
também graça nem faça agora vamos ver um
vídeo que é muito importante que o cambé
que o que foi foi o empenho com um uma
fundação e mônaco pediu para analisar o
vídeo e fiz um teste em mônaco com os
puts com essa história de profissionais
vital ator sutherland escolas
então acho que eu vou para luanda lebre
fazer o cenário todo
vou ficar lá na ilha de luanda calma vou
para luanda a acho que ver o vídeo
vou à escola vem os muse e esses putos
espaço de 33 dias conhecia os testes
todos irão mais fortes disputas da nona
desfoca então algo ainda muito forte
aqui e natural exposição naturais algum
problema porque todos os dias acordava
dizer biel o filho do do fernando tem
que estar no vídeo é porque ele é boa
pessoa não topa
eu não posso ter um filme um projeto não
be não pode fazer isso ele nos ajudou
o tcm terra então então foi assim muito
ficar os quatro meses naquele debate
depois vou fazer os carros não fora de
casa porque não vai seguir seu filho
joão fernando é pá e deu assim mal e
joão gilberto só vocês perceberem que
não olha menino
uma veiculação da url do tório hotel em
londres
o pai da menina
ainda não fui foi o herói
daqui a três meses amiga falando dos
seus fãs eu também vai mudar é o milan
bateu mulher manda nos elos raios uva
rua olhando agora descoberto seja que
você acha da liga espanhola taça do rei
e 14 horas
é mais fácil brincou olha eu vou não é
carro nem como eu só vou me sujar da
moeda entre elas ou não é limpo em
malaio hoje nem se fala isso
o senhor acha que com aquela meta o
caldo moeda para mim como eu só ouço
chefe dentro mas também no centro a
avenida não concordar décima casa levou
qualquer maluco pato todos os shows e
badauí gaúcha europa não contribui em
nada na bocha me pega né da demora um
com o outro
fala muito obrigado e até 10 obrigada
também o pessoal está aqui e agradece
mas liga